so as you get older and
he's saying that if he's providing like
if he's paying for everything you would
deal with it
he can still pay and be out of the house
you know you can pay because we still
have the kid in common right right yeah
but i don't do you guys think that a
dude would pay for a house he's not
living in no you could get child support
yeah so so if he's taking care of all of
your bills right and you have 10 kids
your option now is to leave and be alone
because you're older
or stay with him and work it out and
like you would also be poor and alone or
maybe you take half i guess i think
realistically i understand where you're
coming from but i think realistically
you would stay
because are you going to end up in the
streets with 10 kids no
you want to stay he's preparing like if
i mean i'm very independent and if you
have a good job as a woman as well you
can have kids still and being work here
i don't know if i would have 10 kids but
depends on the situation depends on your
financial situation as a woman as well
you know even though it you cannot just
depend on a man that's the thing like
even if the man provides even more than
you never like
like how you say settle
for like the the situation of like oh my
god now i can raise the family and be
jobless you know no never otherwise oh
why that's great for kids
that's amazing yeah yeah you know to be
there 24 7. yeah definitely but if you
give up on all that and that happens
like if the guy cheats on her right you
are like indeed what do you like you are
do you want to live your life out of
fear though
like is that how you want to live your
life because things could go wrong for
my kids though
okay
okay okay wait let me let me let me wait
i cannot leave my cheetahs i cannot live
with people who lie who are fake i'm
[ __ ] real i cannot just live with
people like i wouldn't if i if i live
with a cheater probably i would see
myself every day in my mind like
thinking how to kill him how to
you know honestly okay i am latinae no i
don't know i my blood
we can tell
it's like boiling it boils you know okay
i would like think probably how to cut
his penis so in so many ways
you know to sell on amazon something
like that
okay okay okay okay but if a girl but if
a guy says that right if a guy says what
if what if a guy said she cheated so i'm
gonna cut her tits off do you think put
it on amazon
no i mean
i'm just saying i cannot leave with the
cheating i couldn't live with the
cheater no i'm not saying that i would
do that i'm just saying
that if i had that the thinking of like
leaving with a cheater that's okay that
would be the thoughts that i would have
heard okay so
i'm not a killer but what you what you
said about never depending on a man you
don't think it's a good idea for a girl
to be a stay-at-home mom
like if she has the option to do that
even i would love to you know yeah
because when it comes like to have the
the child
like as a woman you have like three
months i don't know in the uk though
mm-hmm like three months i like to like
the father to have that those three
months at least you know to be with the
child as well you know i think they put
a lot on
on the female
perspective like oh she should stay with
the kid but father not as much you know
uh i think it should be like equality on
that but yeah i mean when it comes to
she should do something otherwise if
this happens how can you live with a
person well it just that's like just
that's a fear mentality though that's a
fear like there are a lot of like
stay-at-home moms that homeschool their
kids and that's really good for kids
that's real yeah i mean if you can do
that definitely yeah but i'm just saying
you'd have to depend on a man to do that
you know what i mean yeah and so like i
just think a lot of times we kind of
have this rhetoric that we like can't
depend on men but when men don't leave
most of the time
like men again men only leave 30 of the
time
college-educated women it's it's 10.
so it's just um it just seems like
maybe that was like something that
happened just because your parents got
divorced you kind of put that on your
future relationships yeah probably yeah
childhood trauma it kind of got me there
yeah that show
um and it's something i need to heal and
i don't want to project that on my
future relationships not even in a
friendship way no at all
but it's i'm just like
thinking and imagining all these things
that could happen
your imagination goes wild
so i i kind of have like that
imagination process yeah you're like
very active which is amazing but yeah i
need to don't get scared guys okay
no we're good we love him
okay okay um i have some more super
chats i'm gonna read um mentality like
that in the black suit is exactly why
men of value
um is exactly what men of value that
most women are after will avoid because
the person personification and
liability and heartache thank you for
showing the high value man oh gosh
that um
they're not interested
they're just saying yeah the okay next
one is
okay i think is that the last
one sometimes it doesn't refresh did i
miss any before
okay
i i think that zentians was the last one
i read
okay but that was 50 so
[Applause]
[Music]
two more
um okay do you want to read them if you
can because i don't think i see them
i have a producer guys how cool is this
wait read the last one just yeah it was
was the last one um from sentience it
was 50 and it starts with mentality like
okay okay
that's what i was asking if that was the
last one
okay cool
um okay so
um don't cheat on her
um
don't cheat on anyone just
but especially
i would just leave
and you know for not to cheat on me like
i think we are human like we like to
experience different things and after a
while you get bored with the same person
in a way like sexually sometimes and
because i've been in relationship for
seven years and i know that and
even though you love that person he gets
a bed sometimes
but that's where you spice it up like at
the end of the day it's your moment
what's your man in the relationship so
then the cheating doesn't happen
i'm done with this girl
cheating here is actually
you being with someone that your person
doesn't know that you are with because
you are not being honest so so you guys
open relationships out there and they
actually work so so if you said okay
it's getting a bit boring the sex is
getting a bit boring you bleh ah
add this guy in a little bit spice it up
so basically i'm a
like i'm a believer of love and i love
romance and i love all that and for me i
would like to build a relationship with
someone for the first at least three
years let's say that it's just me and
him and after we both feel that kind of
you say you're allowed to get with this
person you're allowed to get a disposal
i probably would share or probably do
something different you know like just
to spice it up sometimes not that it
would be an everyday order so like three
so like threesomes
so you're saying like that's what it
sounds like fine i never done it but
yeah i'm open to it if but after a
relationship is built with with honesty
loyalty for at least like three four
years okay and then after we if we both
feel like the sex is not
wow like before and is getting to a
place that is just like oh okay
we
find ways like
both way i mean we both find ways to
spice it up it doesn't have to be with
someone else or probably it has to be
somewhere else i don't know but i'm just
saying i'm open to ideas you're open so
you'd be open to an open relationship uh
after i built that
that bond and that trust and that but
what do you want with the trust when
it's an open relationship because you're
not breaking the trust once you are
being open what do you feel and what
you're saying so it's not about doing
that because if you do behind your back
behind the person that you are with then
that's cheating because cheating it's
not being loyal
you're saying it's not cheating because
you know they're having sex with that
person so because because you've
witnessed it or you you know about it
it's not cheating because yeah because
she has a point there though she's
saying if i am saying this is an open
relationship and he agrees
and he tells me about these people then
it's not cheating because exactly we've
said it's an open relationship because i
would never but i i understand where
she's coming from it's not cheating but
it's going to be doomed to fail i think
if you just look at the most public
example now will smith has got jaydon
is going through it there's something up
for a man about another pers another man
[ __ ] your wife yeah your girlfriend
that how am i gonna be sitting at home
playing fifa and you're like oh yeah
baby we'll be late tonight
i know you you'll get your back blown up
i have to sit there online with my
friends like
pass me the ball
if you really love someone can you share
them though
you're somewhat true though i mean how
many one-sided open relationships do you
see it with the ultra wealthy men like
nba players yeah drake did a whole song
about their side chicks in front of them
but people classify themselves as value
as high value and then they cheat is
that a high value well it's about no no
it's about supply but again it's about
supply and demand right so so for those
guys like the guys that like let's take
nba players right there there's a dime
and a dozen pretty women like they can
get a pretty woman that can cook they
can get a pretty latina they can get a
pretty black girl like whatever their
type is they could they could have them
all they could have multiple girlfriends
because everybody wants them
they're like the epitome same with like
movie stars and that
so it's it's when i think of high value
i just think the guys that are most in
demand
and they're in demand from everybody
like like take you okay how how much
does a guy have to make to date you
he has to have a job right yeah like not
like your friend because i have one too
so i'm not going to live by my money
but
yeah he has to be ambitious he has to be
responsible he has to be
he has to know the worth of money okay
so how much money
45k
too much too little
it's okay 45k is okay yeah it's good and
how tall does he have to be taller than
me for sure okay so i feel like i'm
dating a minion okay
and he has to be good looking too right
in shape
he takes care of himself yeah he likes
he's hygienic like he likes you know to
go to the gym it cannot be like it
doesn't need to be like a nerd you know
like
can you say a gym nerd
um
gym rat chimera
yeah
yeah i mean but likes to take care of
himself because i do that too so we have
to have that in common otherwise i think
it would be a little bit
um yeah so guys um how much money does a
girl have to make to date you she could
be in the streets right now
she can be sleeping right there as long
as she's beautiful i will bring her up
i'll
i'll bring her into the life
okay so